turning to the troubling police killing
of an unarmed black man in akron ohio
the mayor has now declared a state of
emergency protesters believe that police
body cam video released by the
authorities fails to explain why eight
officers opened fire hitting jaylen
walker more than 60 times you heard that
right 6-0 the protesters also demanding
a justice department investigation of
the police department's culture and its
policies
elise preston is outside the akron
police station with more on this story
elise good morning to you
good morning to you gail the streets
around the police department just
reopened as downtown akron's overnight
curfew is now over but the tension
remains the mayor is asking for patience
when it comes to the underway
investigation we have to warn you the
video you are about to see is hard to
watch
tension outrage and sorrow filled the
streets in akron where hundreds of
protesters demonstrated for a fourth
consecutive day demanding justice in the
police shooting death of 25 year old
jalen walker today we're going to the
power structure activist raymond gray jr
led the march toward the mayor's house
with a list of demands that could have
been my son or one of my daughters jalen
walker is us jaylen walker is me the
mayor declared a state of emergency and
businesses boarded up windows in
anticipation of violent unrest
had a shot come out of its door
authorities say walker fired around and
fled his car after officers tried to
pull him over for an unspecified traffic
violation last week
after walker jumped from the vehicle the
police chief says walker appeared to
reach down to his waist and turned
toward officers who were chasing him
before they unloaded a barrage of
bullets
clearly they thought that this was an
individual who had access to a weapon
keith taylor a new york police
department veteran says it appears
officers followed their training but new
protocols might be necessary to the
extent to which
policies can be developed that will
lessen the number of officers
that are simultaneously utilizing lethal
force i think that would be better for
all involved walker sustained more than
60 wounds and was unarmed when he was
killed police say a gun was later
recovered from his car are you angry are
you hurt how are you feeling i'm angry
i'm pissed off i'm disgusted i want a
new mayor
i want new leadership in this city
it's unclear when or if the police will
release additional body camera footage
meanwhile that downtown akron overnight
curfew remains in effect until further
notice vlad
all right elise thank you very much